>> Neil: WELL, HENRY CUELLAR IS
WHAT YOU WOULD CALL AN ODD DUCK
IN WASHINGTON.
HE DOESN'T TAKE OFFENSE.
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH HE EASILY
WON RE-ELECTION, A LOT OF
POWERFUL DEMOCRATS THAT WERE NOT
KEEN ON HIM GETTING ELECTED.
HE SPOKE OUT ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE CRISIS AT
THE BORDER WHEN WITH US NOT
POPULAR TO DO SO IN HIS OWN
PARTY.
NEVERTHELESS, HE DID WIN
COMFORTABLY.
HE WILL BE AMONG OTHER THINGS IN
A VERY PROMINENT ROLE OVERSEEING
THE BUDGET OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY.
KIND ENOUGH TO JOIN US NOW.
THE TEXAS CONGRESSMAN, HENRY
CUELLAR.
CONGRESSMAN, GOOD TO HAVE YOU AN
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU, NEIL.
ALWAYS A PLEASURE BEING WITH
YOU.
>> Neil: SAME HERE.
THE BORDER WAS A BIG ISSUE AND
HAS BEEN AS LONG AS I'VE KNOWN
YOU.
YOU'VE BEEN A THORN IN THE SIDE
OF DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATIONS ALIKE.
WHAT CAN BE DONE NOW?
>> YOU KNOW, CERTAINLY WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WORK WITH
BOTH DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
IN ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE.
YOU KNOW, WE GOT TO LOOK AT WHAT
THE FACTS ARE.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT STOPPING DRUGS, THEY MAKE
IT SOUND LIKE THEY'RE COMING
WITH THE MIGRANTS.
IF YOU REALLY LOOK AT IT, 94% OF
THE MESS WILL COME THROUGH
BRIDGES.
91% OF THE FENTANYL WILL COME
THROUGH BRIDGES.
WE HAVE TO PUT THE FOCUS ON THE
BRIDGES AND STOP THE DRUGS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT ABOUT HALF OF
THE 11 MILLION, 12 MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED ALIENS IN THE U.S.,
HALF OF THEM CAME HERE LEGALLY
THROUGH VISA OVERSTAYS.
CANADA IS THE NUMBER 1 VIOLATOR
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE COUNTRIES.
SO I JUST WANT TO LOOK AT A
SMART WAY OF ADDRESSING BORDER
SECURITY.
>> Neil: WOULD IT BE WISE FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO JUST PHYSICALLY
GO TO THE BORDER TO SEE FOR
HIMSELF WHAT YOU'VE SEEN
CONSTANTLY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, I THINK ANY PRESIDENT,
DEMOCRAT, REPUBLICAN, SHOULD
COME TO THE BORDER TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU'RE 1,500
MILES AWAY, IT'S SO EASY TO LOOK
AT IT IN AN ABSTRACT WAY.
WHEN YOU'RE HERE AND YOU TALK TO
BORDER PATROL, YOU TALK TO THE
MEN AND WOMEN FROM -- FROM THE
MEN AND WOMEN IN BLUE, YOU GET A
TRUE UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE.
WHEN YOU SEE THE VAST LANDS
WHERE YOU NEED MORE BORDER
PATROL AGENTS AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE RANCHERS THAT I TALK
TO, IT BECOMES REAL.
SO YES, I CERTAINLY INVITE THE
PRESIDENT TO COME DOWN TO THE
BORDER.
>> Neil: YOU KNOW PEOPLE SAY YOU
HAVE TO GET MEANINGFUL BORDER
REFORM, IMMIGRATION REFORM.
THE TWO PARTIES ARE VERY DIVIDED
WITH REPUBLICANS WANT TO BUILD
AND CONTINUE THAT WALL.
DEMOCRATS OPPOSED TO THAT.
DEMOCRATS KEEN ON FINDING A WAY
TO CITIZENSHIP FOR THE HOWEVER
16 TO 20 MILLION THAT ARE HEAR
LEGALLY OR AT LEAST THEIR
CHILDREN.
OF COURSE, THAT'S A NONSTARTER
WITH REPUBLICANS.
AT LEAST THE PATH TO CITIZENSHIP
FOR THOSE THAT ARE HERE.
SO WHERE IS THE COMMON GROUND?
>> EVERYBODY HAS TO GIVE AND
TAKE.
LOOK, I'VE SEEN THE GOAL POSTS
MOVED.
WHEN PRESIDENT BUSH WAS OUR
PRESIDENT, HE SAID BUILD 650
MILES OF FENCING AND WE WILL DO
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
GUESS WHAT?
WE'RE OVER 650 MILES OF FENCING
AND WE STILL DON'T HAVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
THERE'S A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT
WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT.
A GOOD GUEST WORKER PLAN WILL
HELP BORDER SECURITY.
THEN YOU'LL HAVE PEOPLE COME IN
AND WORK AND YOU KNOW WHO IS
COMING IN AND WHO IS GOING TO BE
RETURNING.
THAT WAY BORDER PATROL DOESN'T
LOOK AT THE PEOPLE COMING IN TO
WORK AND HELPING OUR ECONOMY
GROW BUT THEY CAN LOOK AT THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE BAD
MOTIVES, THE PEOPLE THAT
SHOULDN'T BE HERE AND WE TO
THAT, SOME OF THE IMMIGRATION
REFORM ACTUALLY WILL HELP US IN
BORDER SECURITY AS A GUEST
WORKER PLAN WOULD DO.
>> Neil: CONGRESSMAN, YOU DEALT
WITH THIS AS LONG AS YOU BEEN IN
WASHINGTON.
BUT YOU ENCOUNTER RESISTANCE
FROM BOTH SIDES.
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING WITH BOTH
SIDES.
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING WITH A
NUMBER OF REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMEN
IN YOUR VERY STATE ABOUT COMING
UP WITH SOMETHING.
THE COLD SHOULDER FROM DEMOCRATS
IS PALPABLE TO ME.
WHAT I READ ABOUT.
THERE WASN'T A LOT OF PARTY HELP
FOR YOU IN YOUR RE-ELECTION
EFFORT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE FAR LEFT,
THE 3% DID NOT HELP ME.
YOU KNOW, THE PARTY DID HELP.
THEY SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO COUNTER THE VERY NEGATIVE
ATTACKS THAT THE REPUBLICANS
SPENT AGAINST ME.
SO THE ESTABLISHMENT, DEMOCRATS
WERE THERE.
THE FAR LEFT AND SOMETIMES THE
FAR RIGHT.
THOSE ARE THE FOLKS THAT MAKE IT
HARD FOR PEOPLE LIKE TONY
GONZALES AND CONGRESSMAN TONY
GONZALES HAS BEEN ON YOUR SHOW.
YOU KNOW, SOME OF US JUST WANT
TO ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES AND GET
THE JOB DONE.
L.B.J. SAID I'M AN AMERICAN, I'M
A TEXAN AND I'M A DEMOCRAT IN
THAT ORDER.
THAT SHOULD APPLY TO
REPUBLICANS, TOO.
>> Neil: THE REASON I MENTION
IT, THE WHITE HOUSE WOULD
BRISTLE AT YOUR SUGGESTION ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT COMING TO THE
BORDER, WHAT YOU WANT TO SEE
MORE OF HERE.
THAT DID NOT SHOW ITSELF IN
TERMS OF FUNDING THAT THE
NATIONAL HOUSE DEMOCRATIC
COMMITTEE WAS RAISING FOR YOU
AND ALL OF YOUR COLLEAGUES.
>> ALL I KNOW THE DCCC AND THE
MOUSE MAJORITY PACT SUPPORTED ME
AND THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
COUNTER THE MONIES THAT CAME IN.
THEY DID.
THE ESTABLISHMENT --
>> Neil: IT'S JUST THE
PROGRESSIVES THAT DON'T LIKE
YOU.
>> WELL, SOME DON'T.
I ACTUALLY HAVE VERY GOOD
FRIENDS THAT ARE PROGRESSIVES.
I ALWAYS TELL MY PROGRESSIVE
FRIENDS, LOOK AT THE DEFINITION
OF PROGRESSIVE.
THAT MEANS YOU'RE OPEN TO NEW
IDEAS.
IT'S NOT ONLY THEIR IDEA.
BEING A PROGRESSIVE SHOULD BE
OPENING UP TO OTHER IDEAS.
>> Neil: OKAY.
GOOD SEEING YOU, CONGRESSMAN.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
COMFORTABLE VICTORY.
HENRY CUEL